In your program the goal is to understand the cause of our cancer, not just to treat it. Are you
doing that now in addition to supporting the cancer? Or do we focus on that some point
in our cancer journey? So when we did our cheek swab, when I do your cheek swab, I used to,
and there might be people's, this call that I've been with me for years and years, that remember
when we used to tell people exactly what came up as the cause? Well, the powers that be, we did
the powers that want to take me to court have forbid me from doing that anymore. So we can't put it
in your binder, what came up with the cheek swab as the cause. So from a medical legal standpoint,
no, we don't tell you that, but you could get an idea by what I put you on. So if we're focusing
more on detoxification, it's probably a toxic source that came up. If we're focusing more on
killing pathogens, then it was more of a pathogen source that came up that secondary. So that would
have been primary. So that's what I could legally tell you. Now you're going to see some things when we
get, you know, when we look at your mosaics, if we look at your mosaic tests, it doesn't surprise me at
all. If a person's cause and a cancer was primarily pathogens, and let's say toxins didn't even come up,
it was only pathogens, which usually there's a mix of different things. So it was only pathogens,
typically there are mosaic tests of toxins, which are mainly toxin tests, are going to be all clean,
but talked to somebody recently that that was exactly the case. So, but then there's, you know,
I'll say there's more people that toxins are the primary cause of their cancer than pathogens,
but it's used to be, you know, probably 70, 30 the other way years ago now it's probably 60, 40,
toxins over pathogens. But yeah, so we're still focusing on that, and that is what we put you on from
the cheek spot.